Brennan sent me this ISA showed me that
he sold out the Metro Theatre in Sydney
okay and it said well sold out my first
theater and then he said I get this he
was just want you to know brother if it
wasn't for you I wouldn't have any of
this in my life and I showed that to my
wife and I said and of course I
appreciate him saying that but and I
showed this to Stevie and I also but
then I said and I am when people say
this I always say that's not true it's
not true like I appreciate you say that
but it's not true because I suppose in
this particular business I've been
helpful in kind of like being an example
and maybe you know into giving you
advice but you are the kind of person
that your habit is excellence you are a
[ __ ] grinder you are strategist you
work really hard so I don't I don't
believe that I think you would have
found your way either way because that's
what happens with people who win and
because they're they they have a habit
of excellence and a habit of always
working for what they consider their
truth like what they I know with you I
know that you're not satisfied ever and
you're not going to satisfied until you
have the set as a comic that you feel is
worthy of being on camera you know as a
special good and then you'll do that and
be on to the next and so that habit of
excellence of course you have a habit of
gratitude I have a habit of gratitude
when you as things are going well how
can you not thank your friends the
people you love the people that you're
on this journey with right we love being
on this video together but what what is
more more important is that you know I
know you now very well and I know people
like you I know people like Rogan I know
people that are effective you can have
to be successful you find your way
[ __ ] through you would fun sure
people have other things like that and
of all I don't think you stand that I
don't dog dude I really don't regard
mysterion that you know I'm saying like
to and there's other unsure stamps who
have started out there like it's a tough
road I know maybe you chose to do it you
see you could be easily said that's not
for me and what you did is you went I'm
gonna do it well I mean you would have
done it
heartless of whether or not I [ __ ]
you know I'm not writing that [ __ ] for
you I don't think so well okay whatever
the case you know you would have found
your way through yeah it's gonna hurt I
cannot give you ten percent and that was
what I was going to ask for you know
your mother's going to County so if I
don't get a little bit I'll I'll get my
beak wet if somebody's not gonna wet my
beak I I don't know what we're doing no
baby hey my bills
you know I carry mine oh I can't believe
you're not coming Australia but in order
for to get this done your management's
going to have to tell this to the UFC
brass are they saying are they singing
the same tune it would send page
everybody so I think I think the real
solution of this is is everything in a
room because it's not numbers it's
personal it's personal it's a respect
thing on her end which is personal nice
so you have a Brazilian and if we just
talk about we're talking about two
businesses but now let's talk about
let's talk about it from a business
world when two businesses come together
there's usually a whole marketing
understanding department that works on
the infusion of the two business
cultures this one's easy though well
show it for you you're getting them
you're taking a Latina from Brazil who
money's not her motivating factor her
motivating factor is respect
it's family she just bought a farm I'm
gonna be a [ __ ] farmer in the middle
of the farm in Brazil yeah sweet this is
not a girl that wants to live in
Hollywood money is not going to be the
motivating factor like mean Expendables
19 after retires now you have another
company where their culture is money
just money and when they met with Chris
and that like the whole thing came up
about like you know look at all this
[ __ ] you've been saying about me it was
kind of like go the fight game toughen
up buddy it was just saying it to
promote stuff but now you got me as a
boyfriend you know and the whole
Wanderlei Silva in a dress with Dana
wiping she didn't even speak English
when that happened when she had somebody
translate to her what he said do you
know what if
like the [ __ ] sit there and see your
girl cry because somebody and not only
that she has a nice do you notice like
for her needs to go to school and have
people make jokes to an 11 12 year old
that her her adoptive mom has a penis
that's not [ __ ] cool and that that's
not just the fight game no especially
you're not [ __ ] paying them yeah if
you're paying them two million dollars
and they gotta [ __ ] listen do you
make jokes about stabbing a jig say
whatever you want so I did that half a
year jumping you know off of stuff and
out airplanes by the other half a year I
do public speaking and a lot of it is
about leadership stuff and you know one
of the key points when it comes to being
a leader is being able to control your
emotions because they're infectious if
you've ever worked for a team and you're
working for somebody who you have a lot
of respect for and you see them starting
to lose the bubble you can sit back and
watch what it does to everybody else
it's the rising tide right so when your
boss starts losing it you're like well
what's coming on like this guy's he is
dialed in he's got experience he's
losing his mind maybe I'm not seeing
something that I should so I'm going to
lose my mind a little bit so emotions
are really infectious and being able to
control your emotions is probably one of
the most powerful characteristics of a
leader especially if you're an
environment where things are going
terribly wrong and you hear your boss
come over the radio and he's in the same
firefight as you are or trying to work
out a complex problem in the same
environment that you are but he sounds
like he's having my eyes on the beach it
just immediately ramps you back down a
few gears but you have to be taught and
it starts with understanding that
emotions don't impact outcome in any
positive aspect but they have a huge
negative downside I mean it really
doesn't matter how much you want
something to happen or how scared you
are or how excited you are how
enthusiastic that does not infect
outcome unless you let it affect your
judgment so there's nothing positive
that it can do and even like say you hit
target after target after target after
target and you developed a sense of
security a false sense of security
everything's been going your way even
that emotion can be very dangerous on
the negative side
it's superstitious right weren't you
talking about that like it's not
superstitious it just it's an emotion
that's allowing you to think that things
are always going to go in your way and
it doesn't so we start getting
frustrated in it
packs your ability to make decisions
your performance goes down when you
start getting too excited and it impacts
your ability to make decisions or you
make a decision based off that false
sense of security
bad things can really happen so it's it
has a huge consequence and it's just
something that is reinforced from day
one like you have to maintain control of
your emotions and if you're going to be
in a leadership position and we expect
all seals from day one both officer and
enlisted to exude leadership and I mean
the classic line is in the absence of
leadership you need to step up and take
charge
you have to don't wait for somebody else
to do it you step up yourself and in
training the training that we do is
extremely difficult and we take it to
failure all the time like we'll create a
problem that is not fixable and we'll
let people start to freak out and you
stop the training evolution you're like
listen you see how things are going bad
here this is why it's going bad and you
highlight those failures so they can
learn from them in a training
environment as opposed to never
addressing them and then you end up in a
real-world situation and it's
catastrophic